you did write this song and it's my
favorite song on the album called use to
this yeah thank you so good and it's
about a trip that you took to San
Francisco with a certain mr. I think
Shawn Mendes when she looks me well I'm
just gonna say I cannot confirm or deny
cuz I don't want people to start telling
me oh this song's idea because then I'm
gonna have to start bad - isn't the
lyrics okay yeah well it's just a little
hint I can't confirm or deny but we have
seen you kiss a little bit but at first
people were wondering like is this real
is this not real but that kind of you
know lead for you not really it out
honestly did not cause any emotional
reactions at me whatsoever
well we've seen plenty of emotion from
Shawn Miller the pair recently exchanged
public I love yous Camila says Shawn
inspired many of the songs on her new
album out tomorrow it's appropriately
titled romance
I mean it just feels like this is like
this chapter in my life that I'm
basically closing and like giving to
people
my life is in those songs what are we
gonna learn about you through these
lyrics ends and these words that I'm
dramatic
[Music]